MARC COHEN: I'm giving some
folks a little time to join,
so can you tell us what
you've been doing with
Compute Engine so far?
JOHN: Well it came in handy a
couple of weeks ago or late
last month.
I was running some onload
[INAUDIBLE] processes on my
local workstation in my office,
and I was going to be
traveling for a couple weeks.
And so I needed to be able to
access that [INAUDIBLE]
process and do it while
being mobile.
So I moved that process to
Compute Engine, so I could
bring it up on my laptop when
I was traveling and do some
heavy duty computing that
I wouldn't be able
to run on my laptop.
That was really where
I knuckled down and
started to learn it.
MARC COHEN: Any speed
bumps along the way?
JOHN: Not really.
I had a few questions come up.
This past week, I've been
starting to use it for
clusters, setting up
a Hadoop cluster.
So I could just, with one script
and a command on my--
keep running a shell script that
would launch eight nodes
and configure all of
them and launch the
processes in a few minutes.
And it's nice using a
combination of the metadata
system to configure each
specific nodes on some things
like the master nodes.
MARC COHEN: Yeah, we should
probably consolidate those and
produce a best practice shell
script for that kind of thing
because I think that
shell script's been
written many times.
I've written that myself.
And it's a great training
exercise, but I also think it
would be cool to have a really
good version that had kind of
a composite of all the best
functionality and best style
and all that stuff.
JOE BEDA: One of the things that
I snuck in right before
Google I/O was the ability in
gcutil to provide multiple
arguments to add instance.
So you can actually add multiple
instances there.
So if you want to bring up
five instances with one
command in gcutil,
you can do that.
I don't think we've documented
that well.
It's kind of a little--
JOHN: No, I haven't seen that.
My shell just does
it one at a time.
MARC COHEN: Yeah,
that'd be cool.
So we have 10 or so people live
streaming the event, and
I'm not seeing any additional
folks join.
Why don't we get started.
We're about five minutes past
the official start time.
So I will share a screen here.
Oh, just got Benjamin
joining us.
Welcome, Benjamin.
BENJAMIN: Thank you.
Hello.
MARC COHEN: We're just
about to get started.
I'm going to share
a screen here.
You guys seeing my slide?
BENJAMIN: Yes.
MARC COHEN: OK.
So the agenda for this--
I'd like to keep this pretty
informal-- the agenda is
basically a short kind
of tech talk.
And the topic for today that I
chose was to talk a little bit
about authentication and
service accounts.
And then we'll leave the
remainder of the time for
question and answer.
And we have a moderator queue
with a few questions we've
already gotten, but we'll
combine the live questions and
the recorded questions.
It's a small enough group that
if anybody wants to jump in at
any time, just yell and stop
me with a question.
So I wanted to talk about
service accounts today,
because I think Compute Engine
has done some really
interesting work
in that space.
Somebody's joining, so let
me pause for a second.
Ryan, welcome.
RYAN: Hi.
MARC COHEN: So we're
just talking
about service accounts.
And in order to kind of say
what I want to say about
service accounts, I need to talk
a little bit about OAuth,
because service accounts are
kind of built on top of the
OAuth mechanism.
And so I just wanted
to explain a little
bit about OAuth 2.
I'm going to do something which
is probably reckless.
I'm going to try to
explain OAuth 2 in
two or three slides.
People can spend hours
on this subject.
So anyway, the basic idea--
before I kind of explain what
it is, I wanted to just
discuss some terminology
really quickly.
So authentication versus
authorization, what's the
difference?
Authentication is assessing
who you are, or validating
that you are who you
assert you are.
Whereas, authorization is more,
OK now that we know or
we at least have a strong
probability that you are who
you say you are, what
can you do?
What sorts of resources are
you allowed to have
access to and how?
What method, what
modes of access?
And so the primary focus of
OAuth is authorization.
And so that's what I'll
kind of focus on.
Although, there has been some
recent work in the OAuth area
to include authentication
as well.
And there was a really good talk
given at Google I/O by
Ryan Boyd this year--
I think I have a link to it at
the end of these slides--
which talks about both sides
of the coin, how OAuth is
pulling in authentication as
well as authorization.
OAuth is an open standard for
delegating access to resources.
So it's not just
a Google thing.
It's an industry-wide thing, but
it is used extensively by
many Google APIs.
The last official count
I saw was over 35.
I think it's a bigger
number than that.
That's the number of Google APIs
that are using OAuth for
authorization.
And there are many
more external
APIs using it as well.
The model behind OAuth
is a delegation
model, meaning that--
there are these entities,
clients, servers,
and resource owners.
So you're a resource owner if
you own something that's
served up by a server.
And in the OAuth model the
client is kind of the
intermediary.
And I'll have a diagram that I
think will illustrate this a
little bit better.
But the idea is that you
authenticate yourself to the
server, and then the server
interacts with
the resource owner--
sorry.
You authenticate yourself to
the client, and the client
interacts with the server
on your behalf.
And you essentially delegate
access to your resources.
So the key idea here is if you
go to a website and it wants
to get access to your resources,
without OAuth 2.0,
the probably most natural way to
do that would be to ask you
for your password.
Like, let's imagine an app that
wants to do something
with your calendar entries.
The natural way might be to
ask you for your calendar
login and password.
That's bad for many reasons.
It's bad for you, and it's
bad for the app.
The application developers
don't want to be in the
business of storing passwords
and databases.
So the idea behind OAuth 2 is
it's a way for you to tell the
application, I'm willing to give
you access to my calendar
resources and only my
calendar resources.
And you don't have to provide
any password.
And it all just kind
of works correctly.
And it's safe and secure
and so on.
So it's really a delegation
mechanism.
The valet key is the
prototypical way people like
to describe OAuth, because when
you leave your car with a
valet, you can give him
or her a separate key.
And it limits what access
they have, what things
they have access to.
So apps register as OAuth
clients by the Google
Developer Console.
And I'll show you that
in a little bit,
what that looks like.
So if you're creating
an app, you'll go to
the Developer Console.
And you'll step through some
pages that let you define
aspects of your application and
get sort of credentials,
like the client ID and the
client secret, that let you
get started using
the OAuth flows.
And one of the things you'll
have to say is what type of
application it is.
So there are multiple
scenarios.
You can create a web
server model.
That's probably the most common
and widely used one.
But you can also create
a web client.
That's where you're kind of
building a JavaScript
application that wants
to directly do OAuth
authorization without having
to go through a server
intermediary.
Of course mobile apps
are very popular.
You can do command line access,
and we also have
something called service
accounts, which we'll talk
about a little bit
more shortly.
This is what we affectionately
refer to as the OAuth dance.
And so hopefully everybody has
lived this experience.
But this kind of tries to
schematically summarize what's
going on when you're actually
using OAuth.
So you're the happy resource
owner, and you're happy
because you don't have to tell
anybody your password.
You're interacting with a web
server, which at the same time
is an OAuth client.
And through the details of the
protocol-- and I don't have
time to go through
step by step the
different legs of the protocol.
But through the interactions
between the web server and the
OAuth server, you effectively
are redirected to a dialogue--
and there's a screenshot of
the dialogue right here--
where it basically asks you
explicitly whether you want to
allow the permission that the
application is requesting.
And you can either
allow or deny.
And if you allow, the flow is
redirected back to your web
server with some information
that the web server can
extract from the
redirect path.
And it can use the OAuth
protocol to turn that data
into time limited
access tokens.
So the access tokens are kind
of like the final ticket to
actually get access
to the resources.
And they're both time limited
and scope limited.
So you can specify a scope,
which is manifested in this
dialogue by the fact that it's
asking to manage your
calendars and your documents.
Scope in OAuth can be both
operational, like manage
versus read only, and it can
be application oriented as
well-- or data oriented
as well-- like
calendars versus documents.
So it can be both scope limited
and time limited.
The time limitation comes in
the fact that access tokens
typically live for on the
order of an hour.
And there's a mechanism where
applications can refresh those
tokens, the access tokens,
either interactively with you
while you're involved in the
transaction, or in an offline
mode when you're not
even around.
And that's a function of how the
whole transaction is done.
So hopefully you've seen that
before, it makes sense.
But there's some problems with
this model when you start to
try to do things in more of a
server or service-to-service
oriented fashion.
So specifically, imagine that
you're using Google Compute
Engine, and you have 1,000
virtual machines.
And now you have to actually
iterate over those machines to
do something to effect this
OAuth dance 1,000 times.
You're really not going
to want to do that.
One of the important innovations
in Google Compute
Engine is that when you create
a virtual machine, you get an
identity associated
with your project.
And that identity is set up in
such a way that the "OAuth
dance," quote unquote, can be
done for you automatically.
So you don't have to go visit
1,000 machines and do that,
that click-through business
1,000 times.
The other thing that's important
is your application
is not you.
And so with traditional uses of
OAuth, you would register
your account, your personal
account or maybe some account
associated with your business,
to this application you're
working on that's kind of
moderating all this delegation
of authority.
And the scope of that account
may not be perfectly
overlapping with the scope of
the data that the application
wants to manage.
So it really makes sense in this
world to have an account
that embodies the application
and is scope limited to the
data that the application
operates on.
And that's what you get
with service accounts.
That's kind of one of the main
ideas behind service accounts.
So really what you want is an
application with an identity
of its own and the ability to
automatically authenticate
programmatically with that
identity, without having a
human being present
to be clicking
on interactive dialogues.
And that's what service
accounts give you.
So you get a--
first of all, a service
account is
just a Gmail account.
It's a Google account like any
other Google account, except
that it's typically associated
with a project or an
application rather than
a human being.
And the two key benefits you get
from using these service
accounts, or what I've just
mentioned, which are that it's
automatic, there's no need
to do the OAuth dance.
And I guess I didn't mention
the second point, which is
that it gives you transparent
access with Google Compute
Engine, because we've done
things to make that so.
So service accounts are kind of
built right in, baked right
in to Google Compute Engine and
quite nicely integrated
with your VMs.
And I'll show a quick demo
of that shortly.
A couple other points are that
the service account is created
when you create your Compute
Engine project.
So it comes into existence
automatically and it has
access by default to
your project data.
Users on your project team
can act as this account.
And you can also have finer
grained control, like you can
use ACLs to limit access to--
set up resources independently
of your service account.
And service accounts have a
broader applicability than
just Compute Engine.
They can be used in other Google
APIs, and they can be
used even outside of APIs
using JSON web tokens.
There's a whole larger area
that you can learn about,
regarding service accounts
in general.
But really the focus for today
is service accounts inside
Compute Engine.
Any questions?
I've been talking for a while.
Any questions up until now?
For people who are not attending
live, who are
streaming this, feel free to--
the original invitation has a
moderator page where you
can add your questions.
So feel free to add your
thoughts or comments or
feedback there.
OK, so back to the slides.
How do service accounts work
inside Google Compute Engine?
So it's built right in.
Like I mentioned earlier,
the account itself gets
auto-created with
your project.
The virtual machine instances
are automatically told about
your service account and kind
of wired up to use your
service account when you create
the instance with a
special option called minus,
minus service account scopes.
And that's really kind
of doing two things.
One, it's telling it to use the
service account, and it's
also giving it the specific
scope to assign to the tokens
that it obtains for that
service account.
In the example here, it
shows a shorthand.
In an earlier version,
we used full URLs.
But the latest version
of gcutil supports
these shorter names.
So this is giving read/write
access for Compute Engine and
read/write access for Google
Cloud Storage.
And when you create the VM
like this, the gcutil and
gsutil commands just work.
We call that frictionless
because, as I'll show in a
second, the software internally
knows how to obtain
the access tokens for the
service account and then be
able to do everything it needs
to do without having to do any
OAuth dance.
It's also easy to use with
other Google APIs.
There are ways that you can
programmatically access the
service accounts, access
tokens, through
our metadata server.
So even if you don't have a
command like gcutil or gsutil
that kind of is wired right up
to do the right thing here,
there are ways that if you're
building a service that wants
to use some other Google API,
for example, it can do the
same technique and get access
very easily to access tokens
through the metadata server.
So let's switch gears here
and do some live stuff.
What I'm showing here is
the Developer Console.
And this is a project
I just created.
And it doesn't yet have any
clients, any OAuth 2 clients.
So there's an overview page,
where you can see various
things about the project.
But when you do want to do
something with OAuth, you go
to the API access page, and you
create an OAuth client.
You give it a name.
You can give it a logo,
if you want.
You can tell something about
what type of application.
So this gets into that whole
business about all those
different flows and so on.
And then you create
the client ID.
And then you get some
information back, which give
you credentials for
that client.
And then those are useful for
actually transacting the
different flows.
JOHN: Marc, can you go back one
page for a second, please?
MARC COHEN: Sure.
JOHN: OK.
OK, I see what I'm looking for.
Thank you.
MARC COHEN: OK.
So that's not really related
to service accounts, but I
just wanted to share that with
you so you know what that
looks like if you're trying
to do something
with OAuth in general.
So to talk a little bit more
about service accounts, I'm
going to switch the screen share
from my browser to the
shell window.
Is everybody seeing
my shell window?
Are you seeing the
screen fully?
Seeing the bottom
of the screen?
So I'm on my laptop here.
And I'm going to do gsutil.
And I'm going to basically
create an instance with a
service account.
I have an environment variable
that I have set with the scope
that I want.
And as you can see, I'm giving
two scopes to the OAuth
requirement.
So I'll say, gcutil
addinstance.
We'll call this foo.
And I'll give it the service
account scope
equals dollar scopes.
JOHN: I have a question.
MARC COHEN: Yup?
JOHN: The compute read/write,
what does that allow?
I know that storage full for
reading and writing from the
Google Storage, but--
MARC COHEN: Right, so storage
full actually gives me
reading, writing, and
almost everything.
Like, I can modify ACLs
and stuff like that.
Compute read/write means that
I have pretty much read and
write ability.
I can create instances.
I can delete things.
I guess read--
I'm kind of educated guessing,
I should defer to Joe on
this-- but I'm kind of assuming
that read means I can
access stuff without
changing it.
But Joe can give a
better answer.
JOE BEDA: Yeah, I mean pretty
much there's only two scopes
for Compute Engine, read
only and read/write.
And so they do what you think.
If you're going to impact or
mutate anything, you need
read/write scope.
We're going to be looking at
providing more fine grained
controls and policies.
We're trying right now
to figure out the
right way to do that.
JOHN: So this is if you want
one instance to be able to
control other instances?
JOE BEDA: Exactly, exactly.
So if you were going to have
an instance that it was
getting from say an auto-scaling
algorithm to spin
up and spin down instances as
appropriate, then that scope
would be [INAUDIBLE] that.
MARC COHEN: And I think it's
more than an instance.
I think it's like I want the
service account that's created
to have this access, so that any
VM I create or anything I
do within VMs that are
associated with that service
account will have that
[INAUDIBLE].
JOE BEDA: It's actually
kind of on an
instance by instance basis.
So you can have one instance
using a service account and
whitelist a certain set of
scopes, and you can have
another instance using that
same service account and
whitelisting a different
set of scopes.
MARC COHEN: OK.
I guess that raises another
question, but I'll get to that
when I log into the machine.
So I just did a getinstance,
gcutil getinstance, on the
newly created instance.
And it's got status running,
which is great.
That means it should be
available, so I'll
use gcutil ssh foo.
And I'm kind of glossing over
the fact that gcutil is doing
some nice things for me in the
space of SSH public/private
key management, where it's
pushing the right public key
in the right place on the
created VM, so that I didn't
have to use a password.
And it's not because
that's wide open.
It's because SSH did the right
thing, cryptographically.
And the gcutil ssh command did
all the right arguments on SSH
to make sure that it specified
the right keys and so on.
So here I am logged in
to my foo, my new VM.
And because of the fact that I
gave it that scope, I now have
full access to gcutil
and gsutil.
So I can say gsutil mb,
make a bucket, gs
colon Marc dash new.
No surprise, that already
exists, so reallynew.
And there it is.
And I can do things
like echo hello.
I can go gsutil copy
minus to a new gs.
And it'll put stuff up.
So I'm basically using Google
Cloud Storage, using the
service account, without having
to have done anything
magical to set it up.
And if I again created 1,000
VMs, they would all be gsutil
ready, Google Cloud
Storage ready.
So it's not just gsutil.
I can use APIs and
things as well.
And things just kind of work
naturally, the way you'd like
them to, which I think
is really nice.
And it also shows good
integration.
It makes it really easy to
use Google Cloud Storage
from VM and so on.
I can also use gcutil
in the same way.
I can say, gcutil
addinstance bar.
And now I'm in a VM, creating
another VM.
And I have full access to--
I shouldn't have done that.
I have my security friend
sitting here next to me, who
probably just frowned at me for
not entering a passphrase.
In the instance of
mistyping it--
[? BENJAMIN: He's ?]
busily hacking it.
MARC COHEN: He's hacking into
my system as we speak.
So if you do what I just did,
please set up a passphrase.
Do as I say, not as I do.
Anyway, I'm able to use gcutil
to create images for instances
rather than from a VM
just as easily.
I didn't have to do a
configuration step because of
the joys of service accounts.
And the question I was going to
ask you earlier, Joe, was,
when I'm in a VM that was
created with a service account
scope, and then I create another
VM, does it sort of
inherit that scope?
Or do I need to specify minus,
minus service account scope
again to make sure
that propagates?
JOE BEDA: You've asked a very,
very good question.
So every time you start an
instance, you have to specify
which scopes and which service
accounts you want to make
available to that particular
instance.
And currently we don't pass
through any of those scopes.
And so if you give a VM access
to the compute scope, it can
launch other instances
with expanded scope.
And so--
something to be aware of.
MARC COHEN: OK.
So that's almost taken us to
halfway through the session.
And that pretty much covers
what I wanted to show you
interactively.
Let me undo the--
actually, let me switch the
screen share back to the
slides because there's one more
slide I wanted to show.
So back to this.
There's a resources slide I just
wanted to share with you.
And this has pretty much
everything I could find that I
thought would be really helpful
in the space of OAuth,
the Developers Console
link, and
specifically service accounts.
One thing I didn't include was
a link to that YouTube video,
but I'd strongly--
if you're interested in a great
kind of overview of all
things OAuth and a little bit
on service accounts as well,
and also how OAuth is working
its way into the
authentication space,
try googling
Google I/O 2012 OAuth.
And you'll find a really good
talk by Ryan Boyd, as I
mentioned earlier.
This OAuth 2.0 playground is
worth visiting as well if
you're interested
in this stuff.
It's a really cool site,
interactive site, that lets
you interactively transact
OAuth requests.
So you'd say, this is the
scope I'm interested in.
And then you can authorize
the API.
And it kind of actually
takes you through the
dialogue like that.
And then you can say, exchange
that for a refresh token.
Now I have an access and a
refresh token, and I can
refresh and so on.
And I get the requests
and the response over
on the right tabs.
So it's a really nice site for
kind of seeing how this all
works and getting a better
sense of OAuth.
And you can also try debugging
things, if you're having
trouble getting something
to work.
I think that's it
from my slides.
And the next section I wanted to
move to was Q&A. We're open
ended here, so anything you want
to talk about in Compute
Engine is fair game.
Don't necessarily limit to OAuth
or service accounts.
And I'm also really interested
in your feedback based on
actual experience you've had
with the product so far.
So it's not just questions
but also any comments,
we'd love to hear.
So I'm going to switch off my
screen share, and I'll open
the floor now.
Don't all rush at once.
BENJAMIN: So based on the
discussion this morning on the
mailing list, can you talk
a little bit about V6?
JOE BEDA: Let me just expound
on that a little bit.
It's a matter of Google
continuing to build its V6
infrastructure, and
us building the
support into the product.
And so we can't give timelines
on stuff like this just
because we don't want to make
promises that we're not 100%
sure we can keep.
And software development
is a messy business.
I know there is disappointment
within the company that we're
not V6 enabled already.
So if you're disappointed
outside of Google, there's
disappointment inside
of Google also.
And so it's something that--
people's hearts are behind it.
And we're going to work
to get there.
MARC COHEN: OK, thanks guys.
I'm going to jump to
the moderator.
The top rated question so far
is, "What other versions of
operating systems--
SUSE, Red Hat, Windows, et
cetera-- are in the pipeline?"
And that may be also in that
similar category of not
allowed to say much about what
we're planning to do.
JOE BEDA: I can say one thing.
It's that as long as it's Linux,
and you're happy with
the kernel that we have,
you can run any user
mode that you like.
Rolling your own user mode is
kind of an advanced scenario.
But you can upload a raw disk
file, make it 10 gigabytes
with one partition, and we'll
boot the kernel and point it
at that file system.
Beyond Linux, it gets a
little bit trickier.
And we don't have anything to
really talk about right now
about that.
MARC COHEN: One thing we can
say, though, is if you have a
specific need for an operating
system that we're not
supporting, we'd love
to hear from you.
So send mail to
gcteam@google.com, or the
discussion group.
And let us know what
your needs are.
And that helps us calibrate what
sort of things we should
be trying to support
down the road.
How about a live question?
Anybody in the Hangout have
another question?
JOHN: Yeah, I have just
a quick question.
The service accounts, when
I launch a Compute Engine
instance, I specify the storage
account scope and I
don't specify the storage
service account, am I doing
something wrong there?
I remember setting up one
service account earlier on,
but I haven't really paid
attention to it since then.
JOE BEDA: There's a little bit
of confusion here, I think.
Currently there's two types
of service accounts.
There's service accounts that
can be used outside of Compute
Engine, using the JWT flow.
And you get a certificate
for those guys.
And you'll see those listed
in the API console.
There's also currently one--
but we built the APIs with
room for expanding it--
there's one service account
available too, within the
Compute Engine world.
And because there's only one
right now, we default to that.
It's called default so it kind
of defaults all around.
And so we're going to be looking
to be able to have
multiple service accounts
at some point hopefully.
And you can specify what
permissions each of those
service accounts have and
scope those things down.
MARC COHEN: Thanks, Joe.
Let's see.
"When adding persistent disk to
instance, if it's already
mounted, it will not mount read
only as the documentation
appears to state.
Minus, minus disk equals disk ID
comma mode equals read only
generates resourcing
use error."
JOE BEDA: So a disk can be
mounted read only across
multiple instances or
read/write to only one instance.
And so without looking at the
specific case here, my guess
is that it's mounted read/write
to one instance and
you're trying to mount it read
only to a different instance.
So we don't support hotplug
of persistent disks yet.
And so what you'll have to do is
shut down the instance that
has the disk mounted read/write,
and then you can
bring up a plethora of
instances that mount
the disk read only.
MARC COHEN: OK.
Live questions?
BENJAMIN: What are the plans
for DNS services?
JOE BEDA: Oh, DNS.
Yeah.
There are a whole host of sort
of supporting services that we
want to build.
DNS is definitely
on our radar.
Again, I wish I could
give more detail in
terms of the when.
But we think that it definitely
should be part of
the offering.
One of the things that I think
people like about App Engine,
for example, is that, based on
your app ID, you actually get
a bunch of automatic names.
And so there's sort of automatic
registration of
external DNS.
And so as we look towards
doing DNS stuff--
no promises.
But that's the type of thing
that inspired us in terms of
making some of this stuff easy
by default, but then letting
you do more advanced
things also.
BENJAMIN: Other than sort of
guess at what all of the
different pieces might be and
how you say that you can't
talk about when, can you tell
us what sorts of things are
coming up in say the next 12
months, without giving any
kind of dates?
Like that DNS is interesting.
CDN is interesting.
V6 is interesting.
Non-Linux VM is interesting.
Right, so all this stuff,
you're going to
give the same answer.
So let's just talk about what's
actually on the list.
JOE BEDA: Well, one thing that
we have talked about,
specifically--
and we talked about it in I/O.
And I saw that there was
another question on
the question page.
I don't have that link
handy, though.
We are working actively
on disk snapshots.
We think that's a really
important part of the platform.
And so that's something that
we're really looking at.
Beyond that, you're putting
me in a tough
position here, dude.
I mean, one of the things is
that Google is investing
heavily in the cloud platform
as a whole.
And so there's a lot of stuff
starting up, and we're putting
a lot of effort into
this stuff.
Predicting the timelines of
how this stuff is going to
come together is really,
really difficult.
And it's a matter of sort of
how fast can we grow and
sustainably grow
our footprint.
So there's a certain amount of
integrating under the curve in
terms of growth and how much
work we can get done that's
really difficult to predict.
And especially--
BENJAMIN: I'm not meaning
to give you a hard time.
I'm a big fan of GCE, and I
understand that there are all
sorts of variables that
go into this.
But I'm looking at this
as not a marketing
sort of call, right?
We've got people on here
who build things.
And I'm not trying to get anyone
to commit to any sort
of timeline at all.
I mean you can leave
dates out entirely.
I'm interested in the list of
things that you guys think are
most important to get done.
Regardless of dates,
what are the most
important things to you?
JOE BEDA: Let me circle around
with our product management
team and see if we can
put it together.
I think it's a good point.
It's a good point.
I think I would probably catch
some flack if I listed sort of
the list of things that we're
working on right now.
Just because some of those are
going to bear fruit, and
there's going to be some
change of directions
and stuff like that.
But I would love to be able to
share some of those details
externally.
So let me get together with the
product management team
and see what we can do in terms
of getting together not
a timeline but at least a sort
of a rough sketch of where
we're taking things.
BENJAMIN: I'm interested
in your priorities.
What matters most to you?
JOE BEDA: I'm getting an IM
suggestion that we just talk
about the space laser
integration.
MARC COHEN: Actually, I wanted
to interject something.
And this may seem like I'm doing
sleight of hand, but I
actually feel very sincere
about this.
What we do and what we
prioritize is a function of
what our customers ask for.
And so I'm going to
turn your question
around on you, Benjamin.
And I'm going to ask
you, what are the--
three or five or however
many you want to name--
most important things you think
we should be focusing on
over the next six to 12
months for your needs?
BENJAMIN: Essentially, the list
that I'm asking is the
list that is most
important to me.
So it's DNS.
It's CDN.
It's much more sophisticated
networking.
The networking underneath what
you're providing is far more
interesting than what's going
to make [INAUDIBLE].
MARC COHEN: Can you say
more about that?
When you say more sophisticated
networking, what
do you mean?
BENJAMIN: I mean a variety
of things.
I want to be able to define
multiple different subnets and
[INAUDIBLE] policies for moving
between them and then
just put things in them and
not worry about say access
lists, which are very crude.
I want to be able to connect
my own infrastructure with
yours over that, without having
a lot of constraints on
what that means.
MARC COHEN: Like an Enterprise
VPN type configuration?
MALE SPEAKER: Exactly.
BENJAMIN: And I'm very
interested in both Windows and
Solaris, in many ways more than
Linux but at least as
much as Linux.
MARC COHEN: How about other
people on the call?
Ryan or John?
Yuri?
What would you guys say would
be the three most important
things you think we
could add to the
product in the near term?
I'm putting you on the spot.
BENJAMIN: Let me throw in one
more before they start, which
is monitoring.
Your internal infrastructure
for monitoring is
unbelievable.
And I think a lot of people
would benefit from at least
the thinking if not the
tools themselves.
JOE BEDA: Our internal
infrastructure for monitoring
is awesome.
It's also probably one of the
most difficult things to
actually configure and use
at Google internally.
I don't think I'm giving
too much away by
talking about that.
And so finding a way to make the
easy things easy and the
hard things possible applies
doubly, I think, on the
monitoring side of things.
So it's something that I've
been thinking about.
I can't make any promises, but
it's definitely something that
we've been thinking about
and talking about.
MARC COHEN: Other input
from anybody?
JOHN: It's not really top on
my list, but having another
Windows servers instances
available could be beneficial.
I don't prefer to use them,
but there's some cases--
MARC COHEN: Where
you need them?
JOHN: --where I fire them up.
MARC COHEN: Does anybody have
any experience with
frustrations--
not something that we haven't
implemented per se but
something that we have
implemented, and you either
think it's wrong, it's not
working the way you want, or
it's hard to understand
how to use it?
Anything along those lines?
Pain points.
MALE SPEAKER: The limit of
16 drives per instance is
[INAUDIBLE].
MARC COHEN: 16 drive per
instance limitation?
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
MARC COHEN: How many
would you like?
I know unlimited is
a great answer.
MALE SPEAKER: Quadruple them.
64.
MARC COHEN: OK.
JOE BEDA: Let me talk about
the disk stuff real quick.
So one of the things that we
definitely want to be adding
and we know is missing
in the product--
there's a lot of places where
things that should be dynamic
aren't dynamic.
And those are some of the rough
edges that we're going
to be working hard to fix.
So an example is mounting and
unmounting disks dynamically,
sort of hotplug of disks.
And as part of that, we are
planning on switching the disk
implementation, the driver
model, for the virtual machine
from virtio block to
virtio [INAUDIBLE].
And that lets us utilize a whole
bunch of the hotplug
infrastructure that's built
into the Linux kernel and
everything else to actually be
able to sort of remove locked
devices dynamically.
And so it takes a while to build
some of that stuff out.
I think that might be one of
the other things that's
preventing us from mounting
more than 16 disks.
It's good to know that it's a
good future request to be able
to mount more than the 16.
We're also working to make the
hard limit on the amount of
persistent disks that
you can attach be
more of a soft limit.
There is a certain amount of
memory overhead associated
with our disk implementation
that caps the amount
that you can mount.
So that's why that
limit is there.
And making it so that if your
hot section of the disk is
within a certain size, to see
the best performance for
things actually scaled out past
that is another thing
that we know we need
to be attacking.
There's a couple of more near
term, concrete things.
Not big features, not big extra
services, but for the
rough edges that we know we
have to keep working on.
MARC COHEN: Any other
pain points?
It's your opportunity to--
JOHN: I have a question.
For doing something like
parallel SSHing, if I ever
wanted to send a command to a
whole bunch of instances, is
there a way to do that
with gcutil ssh?
Right now I just iterate it
through them on a shell script
and [? bin ?] it to send
something to them.
Is there any--
MARC COHEN: You're doing
a command rather than
interactive log in.
You could throw your--
I suppose you could throw your
SSHs into the background,
although I haven't actually
tried that.
And you might run into
a limit if you do too
many at the same time.
I'm not aware of any built in
parallelism in gcutil for
SSHing commands.
Do you know of anything
in that space,
Joe, or anybody else?
JOE BEDA: I think, no--
I mean that's not supported
in gcutil.
I think that there's a
temptation to keep adding
features onto gcutil to take
on more and more of what I
call orchestration, keeping
track of lots of VMs, what
they're doing, and what's
going on inside them.
And one of the philosophies
behind Compute Engine and
really Google's infrastructure
as a whole is that we want to
leverage what's existing
out there.
And we don't want to be the
end-all, be-all solution for
everything.
And so we don't want to build
a poor man's version of
something like Chef or Puppet
or Fabric or Capistrano, or
all these other systems that
people built and used
and get used to.
And so I think that we'd be
much more interested in
getting the core libraries out
there, across a bunch of
languages, so that these
systems can be built to
integrate with Compute Engine.
And then instead of using
gcutil, we say, hey go use
this other great thing that's
actually out there in the open
source world and has a
community behind it.
And so I think I could
probably name like 30
different features that I would
add to gcutil, and this
would be one of them.
But we're trying to be careful
not to take on too much there
and sort of confuse the space,
and find the right way to slip
the clutch into something that's
really more feature
full than anything that
a simple command line
utility would be.
As part of that, though, we are
working very, very hard on
improving the quality and easy
use of the libraries.
And so a bunch of that work
you can see early on with
gcutil, which was an engineer
here in Seattle working to
build a much better Python
library for interacting with
the Compute Engine API.
And we're taking a lot of those
ideas, in terms of what
he did to make that thing be
a lot more usable than the
lowest common denominator API
libraries that we have, and
extend those ideas both across
languages and across other
APIs at Google.
And so that hopefully will
enable not necessarily gcutil
to do stuff like parallel SSH,
but enable other tools in the
community to start driving
gcutil directly.
MARC COHEN: OK.
Thanks, Joe.
I'm just looking to see if we
have any other questions on
the moderator.
Someone asked, "Are
different MySQL
engines actually supported?
Which ones?" And my answer to
that would be you have a
completely open ended
virtual machine.
And you're free to install and
run any database management
system you like that's supported
for that particular
operating system.
JOE BEDA: I think this
person might be
asking about Cloud SQL.
MARC COHEN: Yeah, I was
wondering that too because for
some reason there are a couple
Cloud SQL questions.
Is a free [INAUDIBLE]
Cloud SQL--
AMY UNRUH: We did have a Cloud
SQL Hangout on Monday.
And I'm wondering if that isn't
carry over from that.
Those topics might have been
covered in that Hangout, which
should be posted online, in case
the question askers are
watching this broadcast.
MARC COHEN: OK.
So that's probably a question
for a different session.
Just scanning these, I think
we've covered most of them.
There's a Google
Drive question.
And let's see.
There is one more here that's
relevant, but I think it's in
the same category that we've
been talking about.
It's asking when snapshots will
be available, time frame
for disk snapshot functionality,
something we've
heard from other customers.
And we can't say anything about
a specific time frame
for it, but we hear the
need loud and clear.
JOE BEDA: And that one's a
little bit special because
it's actually in our
API right now.
And so if you look at the API, I
think you'll see some of the
support for snapshots there.
So you need to know the
shape of what it's
going to look like.
And then the sooner we
can get that out
there, the better obviously.
That's how I feel about
all these things.
MARC COHEN: Other questions?
I think we've gotten through
the moderator stuff.
Other live questions?
Going once.
JOHN: I had something, but I
can't remember what it was.
MARC COHEN: Other points
of feedback?
Things you'd like
us to be doing?
Things you'd like us
to stop doing?
KATHRYN HURLEY: Things
that we just like.
MARC COHEN: I am planning to
distribute a little survey to
the mailing list, so you'll
have another opportunity.
I know it's hard sometimes
when you have to
think on your feet.
But we've already gotten a lot
of good feedback from you
guys, so I really
appreciate that.
And we'll be sending out a
survey, as I said, to give you
a chance to give additional
thoughts.
The other thing I wanted to
mention is that we'd like to
kind of do this somewhat
regularly.
I'm not sure exactly what the
interval will be, maybe every
two weeks or something
on that order.
But I think this sort of--
to me, at least--
seems to work well, where we do
a little tech topic for 20
minutes or 30 minutes
at the most, and
then we have a dialogue.
And so if you have ideas
specifically about things
you'd like to know more about,
or things you'd like to drill
down into, please
send us mail.
Either gcteam@google.com or gc
discussion, or you can also
hit my email address directly.
It's marccohen, with no space or
anything, M-A-R-C-C-O-H-E-N
at google dot com.
And give us your ideas, and
we'll come up with some topics
to cover in future Hangouts.
Any other questions or comments
that anybody wants to
raise before we finish up?
We have a few minutes
left if you do.
JOHN: Something we were talking
about before the call
is to have recipes of the
start-up scripts, have a
little deposit.
You said, oh I've done that
thing a million times, as far
as using the metadata
to fill in parts of
your start-up scripts.
MARC COHEN: Yeah, that's
a great idea.
And I think that's an
area where we can
collaborate with you guys.
We can have a repository where
we open it up to let--
the users, the customers,
the developers--
everybody involved can
contribute things to make a
better product for everybody.
And so we do have a repository
we've started internally for
capturing mostly sample
applications.
But I think we can probably
expand that.
I haven't completely thought
this through, but we could
probably expand the scope of
that to include tools and
utilities that people
find useful.
And the sample repo that I'm
referring to is already open
source, so it's something we
can share freely with the
outside world.
And so we'll try to do something
in that space, and
let you guys know through the
mailing list when we have
something in that area.
JOE BEDA: And John, I know
that you specifically
mentioned Hadoop as one of
the things that you are
[INAUDIBLE] about.
Hopefully very soon, as soon
as we can get one last sign
off, we can share the code
behind the Hadoop sample that
I showed at my Google
I/O talk.
That was written by
an intern that's--
this week's his last week.
I was really hoping to get it
out before he took off.
But if not, soon afterwards,
and we can
share that with you.
So that'll be a more full
fledged sample application of
driving the API dynamically to
do something like [? run off a
Hadoop platform. ?]
JOHN: Great.
That would be awesome.
MARC COHEN: Any other questions
or comments?
Well thank you all very much for
participating, and we'll
try to do this again
sometime soon.
JOE BEDA: Thank you.
JOHN: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Many,
many thanks.